Let's go through the wire frames
for the Settings UI.
Within the detail activity
in the overflow menu,
there's a Settings menu item.
When you tap on the Settings' menu item,
it opens up the settings activity.
If you tap of location,
it pops up a dialog,
where you can enter in your postal code.
Feel free to use your preferred method
for inputting location, such as city name.
Just verify that the data
coming back from the server
is for the location you expect.
Note that there's no validation
on this string input.
If you're trying to make this app
a production app,
you would want some kind
of error handling here.
If you tap on pick your units,
it opens up a dialogue
where you can choose to display
temperature within the app
as either metric or imperial units.
This is basically just Celsius or Fahrenheit,
and that is what this settings activity does.
Remember that you don't want to make
everything a setting.
If you're discussing a feature
with a teammate
and you can't decide on something,
don't compromise
by just making it a user setting.
There are instances where making
a difficult product decision now
will be better for the user, because then
they won't have the burden
of having to decide what the value
of the setting should be.
And remember, there's always
an opportunity in an app update
to add the setting later.
If you add it to begin with,
it's infinitely harder
to take away the setting
because some users
might get angry with you.
If you're having trouble deciding
if something should be a setting or not,
you can check out the setting section
in the Android design guide,
which is linked below.
It contains a workflow diagram
that could help you.
Very few roads often lead
to making something a setting.